[Musica]
parlare di idee è meraviglioso Perché
stai descrivendo con precisione
l'incerto instabile e la prima cosa che
mi viene in mente vedendovi è Mamma mia
siamo tutti diversi Cioè se voi fate la
cortesia Guardate la vostra fila
scoprite che pur tutti avendo due
orecchie due occhi un naso con due buchi
eccetera siamo tutti diversi Questo vuol
dire che se il nostro corpo è unico
perché la natura non si ripete mai anche
la nostra mente è unica e dunque siccome
facciamo parte di un sistema dove non ci
siamo auto creati vuol dire che c'è una
matrice che per definizione per destino
Celeste disegna ognuno di noi in modo
unico persino i fiocchi di neve non si
ripetono mai
ora stiamo cercando di descrivere una
nuvola in una giornata di vento oppure
sai quelli che fanno le carte
geografiche che devono decidere quando
finisce l'acqua no E quando comincia la
sabbia però ci proviamo
Da dove vengono le idee
ma ci sono diverse Teorie e che dice è
immanente sono attorno a noi per darvi
l'idea come un pesciolino attorno a sé
l'acqua per darvi l'idea se avessimo
un'antenna adesso riusciremo a captare
le canzoni che le radio trasmettono che
ripetitori trasmettono Mentre c'è
un'ipotesi interessante che dice
non riesco a vedere perfetto l'ho già
sbagliato È meraviglioso
Platone dice
no le idee stanno in uno spazio lì per
uranio sopra di noi
che è interessante Cioè vuol dire che
questo è il mondo materiale sopra ci
deve essere qualcosa che ha a che fare
con l'energia o la luce e sopra ancora
c'è il Regno delle idee lì per uranio
non è fantastico quindi a versione 1
Siamo circondati da idee versione 2
vengono dall'altro mondo e sono la fonte
di ogni cosa sono origine di ogni cosa
l'idea sta alla base di ogni cosa Noi
probabilmente prima di incarnarci in
questo corpo eravamo un'idea un'idea di
viaggio un'idea di desiderio non è
fantastica questa ipotesi Allora siccome
il punto focale è quanto sono importante
l'idea della nostra vita Vi presento il
mio testimonial preferito
lo so passare da Platone e Archimede
Pitagorico sapete che media Pitagorico è
il nome che gli abbiam dato non in
Italia è stato disegnato negli anni 50 e
hanno dato il nome di due matematici mi
piace questa cosa due matematici
Archimede Pitagora che sono presi come
nome del del
paladino delle idee e che ha Edi che
sapete che la lampadina qui la lampadina
il simbolo delle idee faccio
un'associazione Dunque il nostro corpo è
una lampadina e l'idea è l'energia che
la accende Vi è mai capitato di avere
delle idee
Sì con questo entusiasmo grazie
Ok vi dico quando le avete
prima di dormire di notte o quando vi
svegliate di mattina perché perché la
mente è calma
quando siamo agitati la luna
dell'intuizione non si rispecchia bene
nel lago della mente Se questo è mosso
dal vento delle preoccupazioni Quindi
quando facciamo gli errori perché non
Siamo calmi
giusto
l'attività della nostra del nostro
cervello di giorno è troppo eccessiva di
notte dorme quel piccolo momento è
quello che hanno gli Yoghi in
meditazione Siamo calmi ma controllati
ora Questo spiega perché molti hanno
delle hanno la matita e il foglio di
carta nel comodino perché poi te le
dimentichi quante volte di mattina viene
questa intuizione prendi l'ombrello
perché piove questa la parte intuitiva
ma poi la parte razionale dice c'è sole
non ha senso poi tu di pomeriggio ti
trovi sotto la pioggia e dici Madonna lo
sapevo che pioveva me l'aveva detto
l'intuizione sai perché non l'ascolti
perché non ci credi
non abbiamo cinque sensi ne abbiamo 6 il
principe e l'intuizione È una qualità
superiore probabilmente viene da lì per
uranio
perché le idee sono importanti perché
vengono prima abbiamo sentito Angela
Prima no che ci ha finalmente detto che
prima c'è l'uovo e poi la gallina Beh è
uguale per il Baobab il Baobab a tremila
anni ma prima era un seme il seme l'idea
non è fantastico ora perché le idee sono
importanti perché l'idea producono soldi
soldi non producono idee
Se voi ci pensate qui pensiamo
mediamente che una vita creativa sia
dedicata a gli artisti agli scrittori
giusto invece l'idea servono tutti noi
chi fa sport chi fa politica Chi fa la
guerra chi fa il pane Chi fa la farina
gli Argenti
non è fantastico cioè l'idea viene prima
dobbiamo accettare questa verità
assoluta Prima c'è l'idea che diventa
sogno immaginazione che poi diventa
prodotto vi faccio un esempio un'idea
nello sport Allora sapete Siamo alla
fine degli anni 60 e fosbury non era un
granché Non aveva un fisico potente
prima di lui il salto con l'asta si
faceva frontale e lui non guardava
l'asta guardava il cielo
E difatti ha inventato un nuovo modo di
saltare e ha vinto la medaglia d'oro con
un'idea
ma anche nella Guerra i greci hanno
vinto dopo dieci anni di assedio a
Grazie un cavallo è un'idea con quel
cavallo smetto di assediare la città e
vinco quindi è fantastico perché
veramente se noi ci pensiamo ogni
persona di successo usa la sua
creatività la sua immaginazione in modo
unico Perché Perché un insulto vivere
una vita non creativa essendo noi
speciali quando tornate a casa tristi di
sera è stanchi dovete pensare che il
creato stesso
ha avuto almeno un attimo di interesse
personale per ognuno di voi per il fatto
che ci ha creati abbiamo posto speciale
quando tu vedi la notte stellata non
pensi che tutte queste stelle abbiano un
senso uno scopo e per Steve job la vera
creatività era connettere i punti ora
che ci sia un'idea di interpretazione o
di immaginazione o di rielaborazione
uguale se vai da Cracco a mangiare ti dà
l'insalata russa Madonna con l'insalata
russa anni 70 No ma
è croccante non ha inventato una cosa la
rielaborata quindi l'idea può essere una
rielaborazione o un'invenzione vi faccio
degli esempi
una delle cose più belle che possiamo
ricordare Spero che abbiate i capelli
bianchi perché uno che abbiate visto
Mary Poppins è questa parto io lo parte
la regia
Bene cominciamo dal principio il posto
migliore per attaccare un cappello è un
bel attaccapanni
[Applauso]
[Musica]
questo serve a poco
Io preferisco vedermi il viso tutto
quanto insieme
Ma dentro la valigia non c'era niente
non giudicare mai le cose dal loro
aspetto nemmeno una valigia Io non lo
faccio mai
Allora vedete che nella valigia non c'è
niente la nostra valigia razionale non
c'è niente ma abbiamo un patrimonio
fantastico che non usiamo è fantastico
questa cosa qui cioè noi abbiamo delle
potenzialità che sottostimiamo per
esempio l'immaginazione l'immaginazione
è il primo step per le idee
Come si fa
Jules Verne ha descritto i viaggi nello
spazio il sottomarino e il televisore
prima ancora che venissero
realizzati deve andare un po' più in là
anche c'è un Salgari questo Veronese che
ha scritto 80 romanzi e 100 migliaia di
racconti ambientati in Malesia nelle
Indie tra i pirati ha vissuto a Verona a
Torino
vedi il potere della fantasia
il nostro migliore amico Siamo noi
stessi esattamente come il nostro
peggiore nemico se tu dici Non ce la
posso fare non ce la farai
e sai C'è una cosa molto interessante
che non viene fuori benissimo adesso
viene fuori allora Topolino
ci dice una cosa molto interessante
Certo che tutti sbagliamo altrimenti le
matite non avrebbero il gommino è
evidente che sbaglieremo cioè tu pensi
che Walt Disney non abbia fallito tu sai
che quando hai ragione a lista della
licenziato del giornale dove lavorava
perché non aveva fantasia
avete imparato a parlare prima di 4/5
anni Einstein no ha cominciato a leggere
dopo 7
Cioè se tu vuoi scrivere un libro è un
editore non te lo pubblica anche secondo
editore anche il terzo giusto al quarto
Molly al quinto ti uccidi La Rowling ha
fatto 12 tentativi prima di trovare
Harry Potter pubblicato quindi il vero
trucco è non mollare mai ci sono due
paradigmi due fondamentali
verità uno è immaginare le cose 2 Non
avere paura di sbagliare che fa parte
dell'immaginare treno mollare mai la
determinazione è importante tanto quanto
l'immaginazione
solo con la poesia non levi da nessuna
parte Ma la volontà fa miracoli
Quindi se il fallimento fa parte della
nostra vita come il freddo e il caldo
fanno parte della nostra temperatura il
sale lo zucchero fanno parte la nostra
cucina
c'è qualcosa di magico nella
determinazione
perché noi tendendo noi siamo un paese
latino e quindi tendiamo a promuovere la
parte romantica la parte poetica ma la
determinazione è la nostra parte Adamo
ed Eva sapete una metafora abbiamo un
cervello diviso in due quindi siamo
tutti schizofrenici benvenuti nel club
ma l'importante è che andiamo d'accordo
con noi stessi È più importante piacere
noi stessi che agli altri più importante
per la coscienza a posto per
l'approvazione degli altri ecco allora
il mondo dell'idea È fantastico perché
noi possiamo realizzare quello che
vogliamo e chi non lo vuol fare ha
trovato una scusa meravigliosa per
vivere una vita offendendo la sua
originalità
la determinazione del racconto con un
esempio che mi sembra carino e questo è
il testimone Quindi passiamo da Platone
alle rane vi racconto questa storia
perché è importante per capire
il senso del Never give up ci sono due
rane che saltellano in un giorno felice
in una fattoria Pop Pop e sfiga
cadono in un vaso di latte appena monto
Siccome è troppo alto il la distanza per
saltare fuori devono devono cominciare a
nuotare e nuotano e dopo un po' che
nuoti ti rendi conto che giri attorno
giri attorno gira attorno dopo mezz'ora
Una dice all'altra Scusa non ce la
faremo uscire Vivi da qua moriremo e
l'altra dice lo so ma non voglio cedere
continuiamo dopo 10 minuti questa dice
non c'è nessuna possibilità razionale
non ce la faremo mai E questa dice lo so
ma non voglio mollare andiamo avanti
qualcosa succederà dopo 5 minuti sono
sono esauste non ne possono più non
hanno futuro non hanno speranza e quella
dice non ce la faremo mai mi lascio
andare e blu blu blu blu blu quella che
è rimasta da sola non voleva cedere e
continuava e continuava e sentiva che
gli stava scopiando il cuore era sempre
più faticoso nuotare fino a che un certo
punto il latte è diventato burro e lei
ha potuto fare un salto e uscire fuori
cercava una citazione sul 10 invece ho
trovato quella sull'11 e di Rockerduck
abbiate una buona serata
[Applauso]